In this video, we'll explore importing FAB assets from the cloud.
Before we dive too deep into importing our own custom FBX assets from our DCC tools,
it's good to know how to get data from the web.
FAB is a one-stop shop that uses Unreal Engine directly in the editor to add a wide variety
of assets, meshes, textures, etc. directly into your project.
When you find a FAB asset you like, you can add it to your library or just temporarily
add it to the project to see what you think of it.
For example, as long as I have the FAB plugin active, if I pull up my content drawer, I
can go to the FAB icon here, click on it, and see FAB load not in a separate web browser
but directly inside of Unreal Engine.
Then if I wanted to find, for example, some animations and sort only by free options,
I might find something useful for my particular project.
Maybe we want to make sure that these are relatively recent files, and then we could
grab something like these nice free zombie animations from QuackAvoid.
I can add to my project without adding it to my library if I just want to test them
out and see what I think of them.
Now without actually having to go through a more traditional import process, I now have
a folder called Zombie Animation Pack full of animations with that nice handy FAB icon
to show us where these came from.
Be careful when downloading potentially large files like Megascan assets.
If you choose something like raw data, it's likely to be 8K and very, very huge files.
You'll see oftentimes when downloading you actually have options for things like an
FBX file format versus GLTF, and in many cases you'll get little previews of their
sizes.
This is if you want the raw data.
This is if you want the file types directly, including zip folders of various textures.
But again, this is only if you need that source data and don't want to bring it directly into
your project.
For example, if I search for Quixel African, I can see the African slate query here.
And if I go to the website, I can access these direct raw files.
From over an Unreal Engine, I only have access to add this directly into my Unreal Engine
project, not to download it directly.
And yes, note again that over in my FAB settings, I can choose my preferred quality tier when
adding directly into my Unreal Engine project.
Keep an eye of course on your cache directory size.
If this number becomes too large for your taste, you can clean that directory at any time
or move the location to a larger drive.
In the next video, we'll go over some DCC considerations.